just about every scene of Futurama is
dense with layers upon layers of jokes
and references and even hardcore fans
can have a hard time catching them all
here are some of the most obscure and
easy to miss moments from the hilarious
sci-fi saga in the 2002 episode where no
fan has gone before
Star Trek lover fries dismayed to learn
that after the show's fandom became a
religion its fans all died in the Star
Trek Wars then to make matters worse the
only copies of Trek episodes and movies
were dumped on an abandoned planet Bryan
companies steal away Leonard Nimoy's
head from the head museum and journey to
that world to get the tapes
is on this forbidden world that an
energy cloud named Mel var keeps the
original Star Trek cast Mel var keeps
them eternally young but also forces
them to do Star Trek things like
participate in a never-ending convention
and act out his fan fiction in this Trek
reference late in episode veteran Trek
actors Leonard Nimoy William Shatner
walter Koenig George Takei and Nichelle
Nichols all voiced their animated
counterparts with one glaring omission
James Doohan who portrayed Enterprise
chief engineer Montgomery Scott aka
Scotty instead of the Scottish guy we've
got a Welsh guy named well.she Michelle
George
Walter DeForest well she well she
supposedly doin's agent said no to the
part leading the Futurama folks to come
up with their own explanation for well
she we did some musical reunion specials
in the 22 hundreds but the guy who plays
Scotty had trouble yodeling every
episode Futurama offers a one-liner at
the bottom of its title screen some past
examples include as seen on TV for
external use only and on the 2010
episode the prisoner benda the joke is
what happens in Cygnus x1 stays in
Cygnus x1 that's a twofer of a reference
first it plays off the long used
universally known Las Vegas tourism
slogan what happens in Vegas stays in
Vegas
however Cygnus x1 is a real thing is a
stellar-mass black hole a 700
light-years wide cosmic entity said to
have formed from the collapse of a star
as black holes have tremendous
gravitational pull and suck in anything
that dares come near well what happens
in Cygnus x1 really does stay in Cygnus
x1 that sucks the 2000 episode war is
the H word in which Brian bender joined
the earth army and go off to fight an
alien race of spheres is a full length
rip on Robert Islands book in 1997 movie
Starship Troopers
but there's a much more subtle sci-fi
themed Easter Egg hiding in the
beginning of the episode in an
establishing shot of a 7-eleven there's
a sign in the window that offers free
bag of ice 9 with six-pack on the
surface that's a funny number wordplay
joke on a deeper level it's a reference
to Kurt Vonnegut seminal 1963 novel
cat's cradle the novel follows a
well-meaning scientist who develops ice
9 which is used to quickly solidify
liquid or murky terrain to make life
easier for marching soldiers only for it
to infect the ocean and likely to turn
all water on earth to ice killing all
life in other words it's a natural
promotion for people buying beer at
7-eleven in the 2011 Futurama episode
over clock wise young cloned Cubert
Farnsworth gives bender the robots a
powerful upgrade to his operating system
overclocking him to the point where he
gained superpowers speed reading is
among his new abilities and he devours
every book on the big shelf in the
Planet Express conference room in a
matter of seconds among the titles he
instantly reads calculus advanced
calculus the N NYC phone book The
Basketball Diaries the Oxford English
Dictionary and decline and fall of the
Romulan Empire he also puts away
weathering Gattaca evidently a
combination of Emily Bronte's Wuthering
Heights and the 1997 Ethan Hawke sci-fi
movie Gattaca then for just a fraction
of a second a book called how I
conquered your planet appears in
Bender's hands that's actually a real
book although an obscure self-published
one it's a 2006 sci-fi detective novel
by John Schwartz welder a veteran writer
for The Simpsons like most every
character on a continuing cartoon series
Philip J fry wears the exact same
clothes in almost every episode of
Futurama blue jeans a white t-shirt and
a red windbreaker it isn't much care
that his old-fashioned clothes make him
stick out in new New York probably
because his outfit was a bit outdated
for 1999 all things considered it
probably doesn't bother Fry because his
choice in clothes make him resemble one
of the coolest dudes who ever lived in
any century his clothes match exactly
the ones worn by bad-boy actor James
Dean in the 1995 classic of juvenile
delinquent cinema rebel without a cause
no one else on Futurama sounds quite
like dr. Zoidberg the gymnasium
excellent excellent
for some reason I'm frisky as a squid on
Tuesday according to voice actor Billy
West he got the voice by combining
impressions of two different entertainer
both of whom are almost completely
forgotten to modern audiences one of
them is marble mouth George Jessel a
vaudeville comedian an early film star
who had his own radio show in the early
50s
the other major Zoidberg component is
Canadian character actor Luke Jacobi
when the series introduced Zoidberg
huncle in the 2001 episode that's
lobster tainment writers went back to
the old Hollywood well Harold Zoid a
star from the silent hologram era has a
name and character which rip on silent
film comedian Harold Lloyd there are a
handful of fun facts about the American
presidents that virtually everybody
seems to know for example most people
know that future Futurama Earth's star
President Richard Nixon was the only
American president to resign and a
Grover Cleveland is the only president
to ever serve two non-consecutive terms
in office
Futurama riders buried a clever jokey
reference to this bit of historical
knowledge in the 1999 pilot episode of
Futurama Bry discovers that scientists
have learned to keep human heads living
in jars indefinitely and that the
noggins of many individuals take
residence in new New York's Head Museum
the head Museum features a fall of
presidents home to the actual living
suspended in solution heads of past
commanders in chief including Jimmy
Carter Bill Clinton Andrew Jackson and
Grover Cleveland in fact because he was
president on two separate occasions the
head museum actually holds to Grover
Cleveland heads in the early seasons of
Futurama Leela feels alone in the
universe not only she unhappily single
but she believes she's an orphan and
possibly the last living Cyclops in the
2000 episode a bicycle ops built for two
all her dreams look to come true when
she falls in love with a man named
Alcazar who pretends to be the last male
Cyclops she travels with him to their
supposedly empty home planets of
cyclopia where he lives in a castle he's
a lovely guy until the morning after
they sleep together suddenly Alcazar or
al as he prefers to be called is a
selfish chauvinist pig he demands she
make him breakfast then insults are
cooking before long he's sitting glumly
on an old couch watching TV trading
insults with a dissatisfied Leela who
has done her hair the way out likes it
this end result closely mirrors the
premise and action of married with
children the early Fox hit on which
katey sagal who voices Leela starred as
big-haired Peggy Bundy opposite Ed
O'Neill as rude crude
Al Bundy the word Futurama is a pretty
good title for a show set in the future
about a man from the 20th century who's
astounded by all that the far-off
third
first century has to offer but Futurama
co-creators Matt graining and David X
Cohen didn't just make up that word
according to a first season DVD
commentary it won out over some other
invented ideas including Doomsville and
aloha Mars Futurama implies optimistic
future forward thinking and it happened
to be the name of an attraction in the
General Motors Pavilion at the 1939 New
York World's Fair the ride took visitors
do a miniature landscape of an America
20 years hence which included such novel
concepts as widespread ownership of cars
that used radio signals to keep their
distance from each other which they
drive on an intricate countrywide
highway system with the New York World's
Fair in 1964 came Futurama - which
included such Futurama worthy
predictions as underwater hotels and
moon tourism a slogan of the 1939
iteration promised to look into the
world of tomorrow and graining and Cohen
made sure to pay homage to the original
Futurama welcome to the world of
tomorrow why do you always have to say
it that way in the root of all evil
Qbert barnesworth and dwight conrad go
into business and direct competition
with their dads creating awesome Express
and scoring a lucrative contract to
deliver the daily supernova newspaper to
strange and distant points in outer
space during one of these bike pedaled
spaceship deliveries they zoom past an
asteroid occupied by an innocent-looking
blond boy in a pale green outfit he
catches the newspaper gratefully but
unfortunately when Hermes and dr.
Farnsworth try to one-up their sons he
doesn't fare quite so well he's knocked
into the void of space by the force of
the paper little dim Hermes know that he
might just have gotten rid of loyalty
that little space boy is the title
character from the famous children's
book the little prince which follows a
lonely little boy who lives on a tiny
asteroid captain Zapp Brannigan is as
odious as that come a staggeringly
mediocre man who somehow becomes a
twenty five star general and the
Democratic order of planets with command
of its most important space vessel than
Nimbus he's utterly incompetent and is
constantly saved from complete ruin by
his number two kif Brannigan sails
through life with unearned confidence
and acting reckless military strategies
and thinking he can seduce any woman he
pleases
in the 1999 episode Love's Labour's Lost
in Space Zapp tries to seduce Leela by
laying in bed in his robe with his
paunch clearly visible inside the outfit
behind him on the wall
what appears to be his official
captain's portrait his arms are crossed
and his head bowed as if deep in
thoughts which seems to suggest the
soulful thoughtful leader of men he's
none of those things of course which is
why it's hilarious it's also an exact
recreation of a famous painting Aaron
sheckler's official presidential
portrait of John F Kennedy Zapp would
compare himself to a revered politician
wouldn't he in the 2001 episode Roswell
that ends well
prime microwaves a metal popcorn
container on the Planet Express ship
rise mistake upsets the balance of
radiation and sends the ship back
through time in space
crash landing the crew in Roswell New
Mexico in 1947 to return to the future
Professor Farnsworth needs microwave
technology of some kind and the
microwave antenna at the local military
base would work he warns bride that
acquiring it could be tricky as fries
grandfather
eNOS works at that base and if he killed
him he'd erases existence fry tries to
protect his grandfather as best he can
and to prevent harm he locks him in a
house which she doesn't realize is
located on a nuclear weapon testing
range the test kills eNOS almost
immediately and Pryde tries to comfort
eNOS as fiance a diner waitress named
Mildred but they wind up sleeping
together probably figures that since he
didn't blink out of existence when eNOS
died then eNOS must not have been his
grandfather as it turns out Mildred is
still his grandmother she just became
pregnant by pride as Professor
Farnsworth tells fry oh lesson in not
changing history from mr. I'm my own
grandpa let's get the hell out of here
already
screw history Farnsworth's mockery is
actually an explicit reference to I'm my
own grandpa a hit novelty song by the
duo Lonzo and Oscar
it's a strange tune that details the odd
circumstances by which a man becomes his
stepmothers stepfather and us by default
his own grandpa fittingly enough the
song was released in 1947 check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]